le football était à l'honneur ce samedi
17 décembre à guyancourt l'équipe de
football de la ville organisé au gymnase
de l'aviation un tournoi de noël pour la
18e année consécutive l'événement
encadrés par les éducateurs du club et
est ouvert à plus de 200 enfants âgés de
6 à 13 ans ça permet un à tous les
joueurs se connaître ils se fréquentent
se voit mais ne se connaissent pas de
mélanger les catégories permet une
cohésion meilleur la connaissance de
nouvel éducateur qu'ils auront peut-être
années suivantes des matchs de dix
minutes ont opposé deux équipes mixtes
de cinq joueurs les parties se sont
jouées sur des terrains de handball
dimensions de 40 mètres sur 20 m les
sensations très différente des terrains
de football en herbe le terrain il est
moins puissant et il fait - il fait
moins froid à l'intérieur
sachant que le terrain il est un peu
plus petit je crois
ouais on va dire bah faut faire des
allers-retours enfin et c'est
l'intérieur il n'y a pas le droit aux
tacles des trucs comme ça quoi avec cet
événement le club espère développer
encore un peu plus ce sport on l'a mis
en place il ya quatre ans forcément on
va essayer de booster cette pratique
on est un peu coincée par
bien entendu il nous faut des salles
pour l'instant on est un peu de se
mettre l'armée
pourquoi pas le futsal compte près de
20me licenciés dans l'hexagone 25% de
plus qu'en 2011